-No. I'm aware.
The thing is that the car
was for my daughter.
And she changed her mind.
She doesn't want the car.
Yeah. I know.
Anyway, yeah.
Well, it's a long story.
But I think we need to talk
about the $5,000 deposit.
I understand your policy, sir.
But you got to have
some flexibility here.
Well, for instance, how about,
you know, 50% back?
-Dad?
-Okay. How about 40%.
40%, You keep $3,000.
-Dad! [ Bleep ]
-Let me put you on hold
for a second.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Sean Penn.
This is very serious movie.
It's a very dramatic film.
There are nice funny
father-daughter moments
in the film, especially
about the idea of honesty.
And there is a really funny
scene you talk about
smoking weed,
the two characters.
And I'm wondering,
did that give you flash backs
to the actual moments
with Dylan?
And I'm wondering
were you the kind of parent that
was honest with your kid
or were you a liar?
-Yeah. Well, this is an
interesting thing that we do.
What we convince ourselves of
as honesty
and those things that might
just be adult privacies.
-Right. Right.
-And kids are so --
All kids have such an intuitive
sense of what's authentic
and are all driven to know
their parents' authentic self.
And I think, you know,
I can even say that
while we were making this movie,
still an evolving thing
'cause it's like
peeling an onion
to offer your authentic self.
And there was so much
in Jez Butterworth's writing
that could parallel things.
Not marijuana because I wasn't
ever -- I couldn't take pot.
I'd just hear police sirens
and hide in a bathroom.
-[ Laughs ] It is a paranoid
experience, yeah.
-But there were
plenty of other areas
where, you know, you find
that you were less than honest.
And so these --
I love in this case the extreme
of what
corrosive deception does.
And I felt also, of course,
thematically that part
of the theme was something we
all are living with
in such a loud and present way
now.
-It is really --
I think you're right.
Like, as long as you can be
authentic about it,
whether or not it's the whole
truth, it doesn't matter.
Your kids don't actually care
about the truth
or the lie about the fact.
They just want to know, like,
are you telling me
something you believe?
-Yeah. Who are you?
-Yeah.
There is a lot of -- Music
is a big part of this film.
I feel like historically it's
always a big part of your films.
-Yeah.
-When you're trying
to find a song,
like, what sends you
on that journey?
Is it something in the scene
that you feel
like you need the music for?
-Well, typically --
if it's something
I have written from go,
whether adapted or original,
I have found that I involve
songs as characters.
Music as characters.
And then with
something like this
that I didn't write
the original script on,
I did revisions by making
edits where I felt
that I could tell something
with images and music
that was otherwise written
as a scene.
So the -- And I had such a great
collaboration with Eddie Vedder
on another movie and on
"Into the Wild,"
and he came onboard on this
and really kind of curated
all the rest of it, Cat Power
and Glen Hansard
and then Olivia Vedder,
Eddie's teenage daughter,
beautifully sang
the end two songs.
But, yes, I always love that
kind of cinema starting back
whether it is Mike Nichols
with "The Graduate"
or "Harold and Maude,"
where, you know,
songs could help tell the story
and I enjoy watching a movie
and feeling that music with it.
-You were on about a year ago.
We were talking remotely.
But we were talking
about your CORE foundation,
which has obviously done
great work internationally.
But you're using it domestically
to do a lot of vaccine outreach.
Progress?
Do you feel like things are
moving in the right direction?
How is it going?
You're in California a lot.
-Yeah. Well, we -- You know,
we're spread out
across the states.
We're in India, we're in Brazil,
we're in Haiti, vaccinating now.
You know, started with testing.
There was -- As we know, I mean,
it's not a story
I can only tell.
It was -- There was a lot of
progress early on.
That people have invested in
a very fraudulent idea
of individuality and freedom
and attached that to denying
basic science is disheartening.
That's what I call kind of a
radical Libertarianism
that is a spinoff of an identity
that is going to hurt their kids
in the long run.
And so we're up against it
that way.
We're trying to sensitize
other neighborhoods.
The there are people
who are of good will who are --
have been afraid of it.
You talked about the FDA today.
I think that's very important.
It's also going to give
businesses cover
to start mandating it,
which I believe is, you know,
it's like a bad word,
but it actually means you have
to turn your headlights on
when you're driving
down the freeway
at night.
So there is progress,
and there are setbacks.
Case in point,
we had progress moving
on the vaccinating in Haiti
and then
the president was assassinated
followed up immediately by
another devastating earthquake.
But we put one foot in front
of the other and keep on going.
-I know you're heading down
there right after this.
Thanks again for continuing to
put your efforts to good use.
And it's just lovely
talking to you as always.
-Great to talk you to.
-Thanks for being here.
Please visit
www.coreresponse.org
for more information.
"Flag Day" is in theaters now.